yo this video is brought to you by
square space helping you make beautiful
websites quickly and easily sub G this
your boy dive Suites and this week we're
getting our bromance all with the epic
of gilgamesh
ain't nobody swingin a bigger the
Gilgamesh the king of who not only is
this cat two thirds God the heat of
swirling smartest and finest cat in the
hood
sup Gilgamesh is one cold [ __ ]
he'll ghost is our warriors boosted just
cuz he can and get buck nasty with new
Brides before their husband can either
get a crack at it it's good to be the
king eventually his people's get fed up
and say yo gods
y'all best sack up and put Gilgamesh is
crazy ass eject cuz we tired of it so
the goddess of ruled aside her fine self
is gonna build a brother out of clay
who'll be so gangster that he'll step up
the Gilgamesh and get him to slow his
roll so Sowell [ __ ] and Keitel is
born one day a hunter role is strapped
through the wilderness
what are you catching kid who's Tarzan s
messing with all his traps boy has his
daddy how is he supposed to tame this
raggedy savage and possibly our life I
know
oh yeah as soon as this trick whip out a
titty and Kido gives her daddy for six
days and seven nights straight man you
know this do ballin if he ain't wrong
after that now that he got that stank
all up on him his animal homies don't
want nothing to do with them when the
key to get worried about Gilgamesh doing
his people dirty he said she did
i'ma give that fool of beatdowns out of
sinners balls packing up a nuke
guiltiness bout to get freaky with a
newly berry woman when a kid who step
two would be like my eyes son that be
ain't yours next thing you know it's
all-out brawl in the streets back boom
are you can when the dust settle
Gilgamesh the one on top
cuz he's still dodgy dang beefing though
immediately after they tussle they
become homies Gilgamesh like say brah
you know what would step up our rep if
we win and whooped on that forest
guardian whom Baba and got our hands on
some of them dank see the trees hail you
have to beast it through five trippy
nightmares and climbing mountains
they reach to see the forest and start
busting down trees all of a sudden Roz
come by here with a little help from the
gods shamash Gilgamesh get the jump on
that scrub full star bag and Gilgamesh
to let him live but in ki do like come
on brah
pulverized that [ __ ] I'm Bob I pissed
at a kid who's gonna do him like that so
he put a curse on Aikido say he gonna
bite the dust befo Gilgamesh Gilgamesh
like oh hell no nobody curses my boy and
rips his head off looking like a couple
of pimps Gilgamesh and Enkidu flow back
to Luke
now Gilgamesh is so fly that Ishtar the
goddess of love the war start getting
all up on his nuts after the be his
wifeís but he ain't feeling how she hit
him acquitted with her other boy toys
and shuts her ass down girls so butthurt
that she gets her daddy to send a bull
of heaven to go ham or Gilgamesh's ass
but this bullying guys my boys Gilgamesh
and Enkidu that's right now that who's
behind the bullet did the gods like look
that boy in kilo got to go after 12 days
of being sick as a dog and kid who takes
that long dirt nap and Gilgamesh heart
breaks into pieces so he called on the
whole world to mourn his man and sends
him out of style
now guilt weak and hard about his own
death so he set out to find this
immortal dude named looting the pistol
to get the deal or that everlasting life
I have to be stand through all sort of
trials that ain't no mortal ever done
Gilgamesh finally roll up the hill to
pitch them and be like Sabra how can I
get me a little taste of that
immortality
Oh Nabi be like checking I'll be stood
through the great flood and the gods
felt so bad for putting me through all
that mess that one of them made my wife
and me immortal so you I don't like my
not wanting to leave a brother hanging
who tell Gilgamesh about a plan that'll
make them young and fresh again kill
snatches that herb and stop doing like
heinous
till his plant get boosted by a
whack-ass snake on his way home yes such
that he ain't gonna live forever but at
the end of the day he still got a pretty
ball of City with some pretty righteous
brothers and sisters inside so it ain't
all bad baby
now just when you think the story's over
it ain't for some reason and keidel's
still alive and Gilgamesh and his boys
still going on there [ __ ] like it
ain't no thing what he knew chillin six
feet deep then all of a sudden he's back
buggin with his homie there's some
thrillers go down well not exactly
see this epic poem is so damn oh it hit
the streets when people were still using
their hand to wipe their ass no for real
this is written on 12 rusty ass stone
tablets and the 12th is the one that got
a key do back in the game with no
explanation some scholars think that the
12th tablet is some kind of book DVD
extra that don't mean jacks to the rest
of the narrative others think it's just
part of a whole other story
starting gilding is boiling ending to
know this happy poem got mad
similarities with another text that's
older than the five for one the story of
who the piston and his woman sound a
whole lot like Noah's Ark in both
stories the gods acting real crazy
trying to kill everybody except one
family with the big-ass flood and that
snake who groves on Gilgamesh's magic
weed sound a whole lot like that hater
snake who got Adam and Eve booted out of
the Garden of Eden and when it's woman
drop wise words on Gilgamesh it's
straight from Ecclesiastes so what kind
of crazy sampling is going down here
some scholars think that the Bible took
some of the same rhymes in Gilgamesh and
remixed it to make some fresh new jams
I'll just say that since both texts were
likely written around 2100 BC they
probably riffing off the same stories
now at the heart of this story is a
bromance as old as time
I mean Gilgamesh is so tight with Enkidu
it's like he give gives life meaning
before you meet a kid
Gilgamesh was all about that gee life of
[ __ ] and power but when they see and
kido get murked by the gods gilgit soto
up daddy's holler and every creature in
person in the land to pull one out for
his homie that broken heart made
Gilgamesh put his begging days behind
them and recognize that there's way more
important things to marinate on then
give me a deep wet like human suffering
death and live in a meaningful life you
heard brother recognize that whether you
top dog the bottom [ __ ] death is coming
for your ass and no matter how bad it
hurt when life takes a dump on you the
universe don't give a damn bout your
suffering cuz I'm a real ain't nobody
can dodge death so you best appreciate
what you got in front of you and cherish
the blind you got with yo homies cuz one
day it ain't gonna be there no more and
I'd even the realest Barla in the world
can change that yo thanks for kicking it
with your boy doc sweets you know what
else is super important players showing
off your skills and there's no better
way to do it than with a fly website
made with my boys at Squarespace
Squarespace has made it easy for anyone
to create a smoking website and they're
giving all you well-read ballers 10% off
your first order when you use the offer
code thug notes they have all the tools
to do it yourself and to show off just
how old G you are and Squarespace is
hooking y'all up so help support us by
supporting our sponsors go to
squarespace.com slash thug notes or use
the link in the description below to
sign up today and you'll get a free 14
day trial to test it out be sure to use
the offer code bug melts and you'll get
10% off your order and we've got lots
more videos on the way so click here to
go to our channel page and if you have
them already make sure to subscribe
while you're there
catch y'all next time man peace
you